autism and girls part one when doctors
were studying autism they
only studied males this makes it harder
for
anyone else to be diagnosed because
everything is based off
the male brain this sucks girls usually
end up showing different traits than
guys do which is why it can take us
years to get diagnosed i was 15 when i
got diagnosed and that's considered
early for a girl
i have a guy friend who's autistic and
he was two when he got diagnosed
a main reason as to why girls are so
late to get diagnosed is because we are
particularly good at one thing
that guys are not so good at when it
comes to autism and this is something
we call masking masking is basically
just being like a really good actor
it's where you take traits that everyone
else is showing
and start portraying them as yourself
it's like a lot of copying going on
but in your mind you don't think you're
copying you think that this is normal
and everyone feels the same way that you
do
you basically feel like an alien and
you're really good at hiding that which
is why
i don't seem autistic autism and girls
part two
this one's kind of about autism in
general but i feel like a lot of them
are but a lot of it is just like
my opinion because i am a girl get high
functioning and low functioning out of
your vocabulary
it doesn't help anybody i know you might
think that like
saying like oh you're high functioning
as a compliment it's not a compliment
it's actually like a reminder that i'm
just masking
and it's so hard masking is the most
exhausting thing in the world it's my
new year's resolution actually to
not mask that means showing my autistic
traits
and not you know pretending like i'm
someone i'm not
and just being more myself high
functioning is basically a label
that you can use to be like oh your
autism doesn't affect me that much but
i'll tell you everyone you think is high
functioning
is greatly affected by their autism
autism is already hard masking
is harder it's just like a little
microaggression that is
real it really it sucks okay there's no
such thing as high functioning and low
functioning we're all just autistic
common traits for girls that have autism
now a lot of the following pertain to me
a lot of them also don't pertain to me
okay
and this is totally broad because
everyone's different okay remember that
a lot of people when they think of
autism think of like less social
not super good in social situations and
a lot of girls and why it's so hard for
us to get diagnosed it's the complete
opposite
i am overly social i give way too much
eye contact
i'm really good in social situations
it's also very common for girls with
autism
to have other mental disabilities or
mental disorders as well
i have seven yummy and one of the main
ones is ocd
all of these mental illnesses stem from
having autism but ocd anxiety and
depression are very very common
especially in girls
just the feeling that the world needs
rules for you to understand it
that's why a lot of autism special
interests include things like
anatomy the human body psychology just
figuring out how the world works
it's our way to figure out how to live
in it
you